after spending a fortune on braces to
straighten your teeth you don't want
that new beautiful smile to shift back
to its original
position so orthodontists recommend
wearing a retainer for several months
after the braces come off to avoid any
shifting often times an orthodontist
advises their patients to wear a
retainer for about a year after their
braces are removed retainers are custom
made for each person using a model of
the patient's mouth the orthodontist
scans the patient teeth and pallet and
sends the 3D images to a lab a 3D
printer builds each model by printing
approximately 750 layers of material
which takes about 4 1/2
hours the printer prints resin and a
support material the support material
prevents the model from shifting during
the printing process and provides
structural support for the resin in
complex areas the support material is
water soluble once a model is printed
they soak it in water for 10 minutes
then remove the material with a pressure
washer a technician places the model in
a vise using a pre-formed clasp made of
stainless steel wire she fits the wire
around the first Muller bending it with
pliers to fit snugly around the
tooth then she bends the end in a
specific shape this step will help to
Anchor the wire in the retainer acrylic
pallet at a later time she Clips off
excess wire and repeats these steps for
the opposite
side once both clasps are in position
the technician secures them with sticky
wax next she assembles the front of the
retainer called the labial bow to do so
she bends a piece of wire against a form
then she marks where to bend the wire to
create an adjustment loop on each side
the laal bow is secured to the model
with
wax using a pulse welder a technician
tacks the labial bow and the clasps
together he applies flux a chemical that
preps an area for
soldering he also applies a heat
shielding product to prevent the wires
from
overheating next the labial bow solder
to the clasp with a silver based solder
that's safe to
wear he steams off the wax removes the
finished retainer wire from the model
and polishes the solder
joint the retainer palette is made of
acrylic and comes in multiple
colors a technician waxes the wire onto
the model then applies the acrylic to
the pallet embedding the ends of the
wire the acrylic is made up of liquid
and powder which react when MI mixed she
applies about three layers of each to
the pallet producing an 8 in thick
mold the excess acrylic is trimmed off
with a
knife then the model is placed into a
pressure cooker for 10 minutes the
pressure removes air bubbles in the
acrylic while the heat speeds up the
curing when the acrylic is ready the
technician uses a steam gun to melt the
wax holding the wire to the
model she removes the fully formed
retainer off the
[Music]
model she trims the acrylic with a
grinding wheel to smooth out rough areas
and refine the
[Music]
shape with a hand tool she Smooths the
entire surface so it won't irritate the
patient's
mouth another technician runs the
acrylic pallet against a muslin rag
wheel with pmus a natural
abrasive this makes the surface
glossy he applies a greaseless Polishing
Compound to another muslin rag wheel and
polishes the acrylic to a high
[Music]
shine finally he drops the retainer into
an ultrasonic clean in machine
containing mild acid the combination of
acid and sonic waves removes the pmus
and polish
residues once the retainer has been
rinsed with water and dried it's placed
in a storage case now it's ready to be
shipped to the
orthodontist no one knows who came up
with the idea of squeezing oranges to
make juice the popularity of orange
juice increased dramatically in the
middle of the 20th century as techniques
were developed to Extended shelf life
today many people start their day with a
tall glass of
OJ in its purest form orange juice is
fresh squeezed and made with no
preservatives or other
additives the appeal is indisputable
fresh squeezed OJ contains vitamin C and
the flavor is
authentic orange juice production starts
in
groves the trees take several months to
bear fruit and are harvested in early
November picking oranges is a job that's
done entirely by hand an automated
picking system could damage both the
trees and the
fruit the Picker uses a bag made of
vinyl composite that's lightweight and
heavy
duty there are multiple types of juicing
oranges this one is called the
Hamlin Hamlin oranges are small and
juicy the trees they grow on are
productive and resilient to cold the
Picker plucks the fruit from the trees
before they turn orange they may be
green on the outside but they are still
sweet on the inside the fruit size and
condition are indications of maturity
and
flavor as the Picker empties the bag
into a bin he examines the
oranges anything with tears or punctures
may also have internal degradation but
superficial flaws won't affect the
quality of the
juice the oranges are taken to a
processing facility and transferred to a
sloped
Chute the gradient of the Chute prevents
damage as the oranges tumble into a wash
station a sprayer sprays soapy water
onto the oranges as spiraling nylon
brushes scrub and clean while
simultaneously moving them
[Music]
forward after the wash another sprayer
rinses them off as the spiraling brushes
continue
scrubbing the oranges transition to a
roller conveyor that takes them up and
under drying
fans as the oranges exit the dryer an
inspector checks them for any misted
damage
[Music]
the oranges travel across more revolving
brushes the bristles on these brushes
are gentler than on the first group they
buff the skin of the fruit and remove
any residual
dirt finally the oranges fall off the
conveyor line into a
bin now cleaned the oranges can be
Juiced with no contaminants that could
spoil either the product or juicing
Machinery as a final precaution the
juicing operator performs one last
inspection if she's completely satisfied
with her cleanliness and general
condition she loads the oranges into the
extractor there's no need to slice them
beforehand she feeds them to the juicing
machine
hole the system feeds the oranges one at
a time to the extractor the extractor
punctures the fruit and metal teeth peel
away the skin it squeezes out the juice
while simultaneously filtering out the
seeds and the membrane between the Flesh
of the orange and the
skin the juice flows into a
vat a screen in the vat filters the pulp
to the desired
consistency there are several different
filters for different amounts of Pulp
the juice is bottled in
jugs the plastic jugs will accommodate
any expansion of the unpasteurized juice
due to
[Music]
fermentation instead of pasteurizing
this fresh squeezed juice it is chilled
immediately the unpasteurized orange
juice won't have an extended shelf life
but the trade-off is an unaltered flavor
and
color Refrigeration will preserve the
juice for a few days and after all fresh
squeezed orange juice is a drink that's
best sered
[Music]
cold